[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream q a where cats are
disappointed that they are not getting
creamed this week
but we had an incident last week in
which a cat nearly threw up
on camera and nobody needs that so we
are uh we are
retooling our cat everyone loses because
of the behavior of one
bad cat yeah i don't really blame them
but no
i don't but uh it's sort of apropos
yeah the other cats are like what we did
nothing wrong we've looked forward to
our treats
what is going on here all right well
yeah um tons of good questions this week
guys
um and uh as always we will pick up a
few of them next week but
we'll not we're not gonna be able to get
through as many of these as i would like
so we're just gonna
jump right into it beginning with just a
couple from last week
um i see posts on social media making
the claim that puberty blockers are
completely reversible
this doesn't seem possible but is there
data on this
i do not have time to go look to see
actually what the state of the
literature is
but i can guarantee you regardless of
whether there's data sets
or not that puberty blockers are not
completely reversible
i know it for sure 100 yeah they can't
be they can't be
100 it can't be because development
proceeds down different pathways
based on what uh hormones are present in
your blood
and so that period of time in which you
have blocked the hormones that would be
there or added hormones that
wouldn't have been there will two
different things right we're just
talking about puberty blockers here
i'm just saying in either case the point
is there's a developmental period
in which there will be effects that are
irreversible
that takes place so you know it's it's a
logical certainty
yeah yes and yeah i have
a lot more to say on this maybe we just
leave it at that
if everything is unfortunately you can't
wield that as a bludgeon because like
two evolutionary biologists said so as
opposed to here's the paper
but uh it's there's there's no way this
is gonna as if yours the paper was
actually proof of something
right uh if everything is a subjective
sociolinguistic construct
how can postmodern leftists claim with a
straight face that their ideas are any
more or less correct than others
i've never seen a postman leftist with a
straight face
i don't know what that means
um just trying to like yeah slam
postmark leftists without actually
saying anything so they can't be like
did you hear what she said about us
right no but i said we had a wait what
this person makes a good point i think
many of us have realized this and in
fact if you look
inside of the literature of
post-modernism
uh you will you will find
that uh darida and foucault
i believe it is daradan foucault each
make this point that effectively their
point is this is a weapon
their point is not that this is
logically consistent but this is used to
destroy logical consistency
in order to accomplish something and as
they never said more power to us
quietly yes to themselves but yeah
the the very logical inconsistency you
point to is there and actually
the degree of logical inconsistency
across this entire landscape
is so amazing once you begin to
scrutinize things and try to take two
ideas
expressed in two different paragraphs
and see how they live together
yep so anyway that tells you the tale
these are not logical people attempting
to accomplish something logical
even though they swear that they are
right
and people never lie
uh do you think wait what happened
okay do you think the dmt being such a
good fit for our receptors is an
adaptation
or just a coincidence that's not a
coincidence
yeah i would say basically you have
creatures using so basically you have
uh hormones and neurotransmitters are
molecular signals that signal from one
place to another neurotransmitters over
very short distances hormones over long
distances
but in any case the lock and key nature
of these things
allows messages to be transmitted the
messages can be
altered and the creatures that create
hallucinogens often create them to
disrupt the systems that are in
communication with themselves
triggering uh anomalous thought patterns
so anyway no it's it's an it's an
evolution it's an adaptation
in the sense that either you've built a
molecule to send a message that is
meaningful
or some other creature has built a
molecule to disrupt the meaningful
processing of messages
for two different reasons so i suspect
actually did you say i don't actually
know enough about dmt where what's it
from um i believe there are several
things that produce
dmt okay um is it one of the towed ones
components
uh i believe there's a toad yeah okay
isn't it also one of the components in
ayahuasca
yeah in which case it's one of a bunch
of vines or
so right okay so um i suspect
um then that the question is
what i suspect i may be wrong but what
the person was actually asking
um is not on the toad or the
vine end but on the human end right so
clear 100 in adaptation on the part of
the organisms
producing it that it disrupts us um and
i guess the answer therefore is that um
that it it
it has to be it's like it's like this
spell it out
if let's say that your enemy figures out
how to deploy
a robot that pulls your accelerator
pedal to the floor
unexpectedly in your car right
does this works not it's not great but
go with me all right
so your enemy has built this robot
the robot is an adaptation on the part
of your enemy who's trying to hurt you
by getting you to do something that you
don't mean to do accelerate when you
don't want to
right the accelerator is itself an
adaptation
for modulating the speed of your car to
make it useful
and the point is your enemy being
hostile to you
takes an adaptation that you yourself
use to do productive things and causes
you to harm yourself
by triggering it when you don't expect
it so you've got a system
that processes information with
neurotransmitters
and then you've got a lot of things out
there that let's say that you decide
oh that plant looks delicious and you
start to munch on the plant the plant's
interest is to get you
not only to stop eating the plant but to
remember not to eat the plant in the
future
and one way of doing that is to take
your thought process which is normally
well regulated and lets you know what's
going on and confuse it
so it's sort of like that yeah again
uh something to talk about more and
actually um we do spend a little bit of
time
on anthogens in our book as well
um how do this this is from the discord
this week
how do we overcome the understandable
distrust of poor and disadvantaged
communities towards relatively well-off
intellectuals such as yourselves
when cautioning against the dangers of
radical societal change
it could be easy for them to
misinterpret it as you defending the
status quo and your own relative
privilege at their expense
yep that's a good question um well i
would say you know this is why
we frequently talk about the fact that
actually
even just hesitate to say objectively
but
the uh the political compass test is
objective in one
sense right the questions don't know who
is being asked them
right and they render a judgment uh
across
uh any set of answers and the point is
look yes if we were trying to prevent
the system
from being changed there are two reasons
that we could be trying to prevent it
from being changed either because we
think change will make the system worse
or because we think change puts us at
advantage and we'd like to protect that
advantage
but that's not the argument we're making
right
as progressives we are both interested
in positive change and
you know you don't have to believe us we
could be lying but assuming we're not
lying if you ask us what system we would
like to see emerge
one that is a great deal fairer than the
one we've got and actually i think
you and i would both agree that the
system uh
while it does provide an awful lot of
opportunity
and a lot of uh it generates a lot of
wealth that
the opportunities in it are very
unfairly distributed
and you know the fact that the zip code
you're born into has a lot to say about
what your
you know the ceiling of success that you
are likely to run into
uh might be tells you that the system is
not where it needs to go and so
um you know you can you can tell very
clearly that we're not
defending the status quo because we're
not advocating for the status quo but we
are advocating
um don't make it worse you know the fact
that the status quo is imperfect
is not an argument for destroying it
because it is far
more perfect than the alternative chosen
at random
you know so something something like
that yes we would like to see a system
that is better what does better mean
it means uh produces more wealth more
fairly distributed
and is less destructive of long-term
well-being
yep um and uh you know assuming we're
telling the truth about that then
it isn't the status quo that we're after
good okay we have a number of comments
and questions
about about portland um and this first
one is
a question and there are a number of
questions in here but i'm going to read
the first one we're going to talk to it
and then speak to it and then i'm going
to read just a bunch of them
so that we get um through them and then
we can riff a little bit about on what
we hear here sure okay so this first one
is you speak as if the setup you speak
as if the set of cleanup volunteers and
the set of rioters are disjoint
how much overlap is there what does it
mean if the overlap is significant
that would be fascinating if it was
actually the same people and i would
actually that would change
what i think is going on a lot but i see
no evidence at all that there is
any overlap in fact of the i think i
counted 11 different volunteers that we
saw today
and um one of the last two as we were
walking back to our car
um was actually wearing a black lives
matter t-shirt and i commented to you
yep i said um wow that's a level oh
there's a spider
on the table crawling up your oh my god
it's probably in your shirt now all
right
i'm cool with this i like spiders i
don't
it's on my sleeve though we're good
let me know if you see it again i'm the
one wearing loose pants
i'm gonna curl up my leg okay um it's a
fast moving so it came from here so
maybe it's done with me
okay there's there's someone one of
these volunteers was wearing a black
lives matter t-shirt and i said to you
that is a a remarkable level of
cognitive dissonance
to be here cleaning up from the riots um
and then be proclaiming
um something that you know really i
again i don't feel like
any of the stuff that's going on at the
at the literal rioting and looting level
in portland right now is actually black
lives matter
it's completely tightly joined and it's
confused the anarchists and the looters
and the vandals and everything have
confused people
and want that to be their branding but i
don't i don't think it mostly is but
but still you know to be like oh you
know i'm for this thing that claims to
be doing this destruction and now i'm
out here
cleaning out the destruction seems like
um a level of confusion that i wouldn't
normally expect but really
no one else that i saw a was wearing any
of the branding but
also i mean these mostly were either
young like
high school and like cleanly like
cleanly quaffed and sort of almost like
properly dressed if that's even a thing
anymore like t
uh high schooler and college age kids
and then
like middle aged there were there were a
couple of middle-aged asian women
and um it just it was it's not the same
people
who are out there i mean we weren't out
there last night but we've see
we've been out there in other times it
was totally different from the people
who were
hanging out outside their tents feeling
you know
being however they're being like it's
not them either who's doing it in the
clean up
i don't know if they were involved in
the rioting zero reason to expect
overlap
i do wonder given your point about who
was doing cleanup if something has
caused
those with a public service requirement
in high school or something to end up
there were two different sets of
t-shirts that i saw on the
volunteers as if there are two different
organizations ngos of some certain
non-governmental organizations of some
sort who are sending out people to clean
up
yeah um and yeah the younger people all
i don't remember i'm gonna have the
pictures but i don't remember offhand
i think they were all were wearing the
one type of shirt and then
a bunch of the other people wearing
something else so there might be yeah
i will say it might be that one of the
things i didn't i didn't capture it this
morning but
one of the things that disturbs me most
about the wanton destruction
is how frequently things like trash cans
are destroyed
and i think the point is the instinct is
to
turn portland into a mess it is
completely antithetical to the impulse
to clean up
after the mess right so the idea anybody
who likes portland to be a nice place
wants there to be trash cans that get
emptied
because then there isn't trash all over
the place so you know do you
want homeless people to have a better
quality of life trash cans contribute to
that yes
right so you know there's just no
argument that this
is uh complex these are people who
[Music]
just see structure as antithetical and
have set about destroying it and those
who would set about cleaning it up
whatever their impulse it is different
yeah
um so just a few
a few comments here and uh several and
will riff
one person says i went down i went
downtown for the first time in over a
year
and my heart broke because i saw what
they've done to my city it's childlike
misdirected anger
i saw your street photos and felt i was
watching guilty portland parents
cleaning up after their poorly raised
and riotous offspring
are they enablers
if a rioter breaks a window in the
forest and no one is around to fear it
are all cops still bastards
that is philosophical portland might not
have all its ducks in a row but its cats
better get in line
um this is a little worrying i just want
everyone to be aware that the insanity
on the left has started screenshotting
super chats and using it as a weapon
against the talent
i don't know what the evidence for that
is but that's not good i don't even know
what that would mean but it doesn't
sound good
yeah i mean i don't i see oh i get it i
see very little in our super chats that
are bad but
um please start a movement to stop
cleaning up after riots so people deal
with the consequences
uh merci love you for more story time
here i'm not sure what story time is
um and then two more and then we'll talk
about
any of these we are talking about i
appreciate your covering the riots and
downtown pdx
portland as a resident of downtown i
find that more support
as a resident of downtown i find that
most portlanders are willfully question
mark
ignorant of what is really going on in
our city yeah
i think so um one more why does the left
media and
black lives matter martyr men who have
been criminally violent towards women
and then never mention the charges
and that's you know a little bit
different and so let's definitely get to
that one but
anything from all of those interesting
and uh diverse
comments about portland i mean we spent
a lot of time talking about and i
appreciate
i always appreciate hearing from people
um who are well familiar with portland
who are here
um yeah and you know we actually so like
four or five people
that recognized us when we were down
there today and that was
intriguing of course you know people who
are interested in what's happening to
portland who live here are likely to
have gone down and likely
right so you know it's it's certainly
not a random sampling but
no but when we moved here so
getting recognized as a phenomenon of
life
pretty rare but um portland was the
place that used to happen least when we
moved here
at least of anywhere we traveled and um
so i do think people people are tuning
in more
yeah locally which is great the
the issue of people not really knowing
what's going on in portland
even people who live here is i think
huge and it's it's not an accident
yeah part of it is kovit has meant that
people who might be downtown more
frequently don't go
um but a there has been a concerted
effort which i've watched
on the portland subreddit to portray
reports of mayhem as false
as you know slanderous yeah
and they're not right the mayhem is real
and in any case there's also an
instinct to look away right for those
especially people who
initially were excited about black lives
matter because they didn't read the fine
print
right those people have been
rationalizing
ever crazier ever more disconnected
behavior
and um it it does result in this sense
of like
why are we not you know why is andy no
the source of information on what's
going on with the rioters
right now i like you quite a bit
but the point is there should be
everybody should be fascinated by what's
happening in a major american city
and instead the press is complicit in
not reporting it
and so what we have is so you don't mean
why is andy now doing this
like why why aren't there 20 andy does
right so that we can get you know like
you know we have literally our 17 year
old son's friend
happens to be there last night and we're
showing video from him
you know from
[Music]
why is that where we're getting video
why isn't there actually journalism
being done right there's no journal and
in fact i went because we aren't like
we're not journalists we're not
pretending to be journalists
right it's not our job but um but the
fact is there is a
journalistic vacuum surrounding what's
taking place
and what is reported is reported in such
strange ways
right so i went looking for information
on the mural
that was painted on the apple store
because i wanted to make sure that apple
hadn't commissioned it which i was sure
they hadn't
but i wanted to make certain yeah and if
you look at the reports
they're deliberately ambiguous right
this person
chose to effectively graffiti
the wall that apple had put up to cover
the broken windows
now it happens they did an artistically
cogent job right but that shouldn't
matter
the point was maybe we decide that we
like this mural but the point is
somebody still decided
to violate the law and put up a mural
that spoke to their beliefs and not
our beliefs not apple's belief right
they chose to spray paint a wall
and anyway in the reports you have to
read
really carefully to figure out what
actually happened how that mural ended
up there
um so anyway yes there's a there's a
completely bizarre field of distortion
around
all the stories i would i mean probably
the people who
are in or around portland who are
watching this have done this
but i i actually encourage people to
spend time
downtown in particular um you know we
haven't gone back at night
since the regular riot stopped you know
i just went down maybe a couple times
and i think you went down
one or two times more than that
but i have gone downtown many many times
in the daytime
and depending on if something just
happened the last night i may park up
actually at like at the japanese garden
which is a fair ways away and walk down
just just so i don't have to worry about
like is my car gonna be vandalized
you know by the time i get back to it um
and it's always changing
and it's fascinating every time it's an
education every time
you know the number of for a while there
in the end of the summer
if i got downtown by you know between
9 and 10 30 in the morning i always saw
shopkeepers out on the street
um cleaning up the mess from the night
before and it's not that shopkeepers
don't
don't normally make sure to keep the
sidewalks in front of their stores
particularly clean
but this was a different level of
cleanup that they were being required to
do effectively in order to present a
welcoming
um storefront um that really should not
have fallen on them
right you know especially especially in
these times when so much has already
fallen on small businesses
um and i will say you know i hate this
trip i've always hated it since long
before the
pseudo left has been using it but like
i'm just so tired i just i just can't do
anything i'm just so tired like most
people use this and like
stop doing all the stupid things you're
doing and like get some rest and then do
the things you actually want to do and
stop using this as an excuse
right now people are legitimately
exhausted because of
it like people are legitimately
exhausted and i do think that there are
some number of people
who if they went downtown and they saw
it they would know something different
than what they currently know
but they just cannot bring themselves to
and it is about
13 months of unprecedented
pandemic horribleness at all levels
well i think it's an added factor i've
always been
struck by the odd phenomenon of being
embarrassed on someone else's behalf
right when you see somebody do something
embarrassing and you feel embarrassment
on their behalf and your instinct is to
kind of obscure what they're doing
and you know and i have the sense that
this is so because we believe in the
dignity of human beings at some level
right and you know this is shameful
right as a
as a portlander i want to be proud of
portland there's a lot that's
marvelous here but i'm ashamed of what
portland is doing i'm ashamed that
portland is
allowing this to happen right and so
i think many people who don't
have our role are looking away
because it makes it less bad except it
doesn't what it means is that actually
they're getting hoodwinked that you've
got a lot of people
who are um basically just
misanthropic and to allow the
misanthropes to rule to
you know create a bailout fund and all
of this
it'd be hard if you looked at what
they're doing if you looked at what they
spray paint on the walls
right it's hard to imagine what would
move you to want them bailed out
right right i want them to suffer enough
that they stop yeah they're advocating
murder yes they're openly advocating
murder with a literal smiley face
yeah right so and so what finally on
this topic
um at least for this set of questions um
why do we see the like martyring of men
who have actually
been engaged in violence against women
like
i i feel like we've talked about this a
little bit certainly we have
um but i think we've talked about it
some on air before and i am
this is one of the things for me that
just sort of you know tears the
the facade off yeah it's like oh you you
don't you don't care about women
right you don't care about fill in the
blank like you don't care about
any number of these things that you say
you care about unless it serves your
particular goal in the moment
and then you can then you can make a
claim that that's what you care about
but
um no it's it's true that there have
been a number of men
who have um died at the hands of police
who have been who have been separately
engaged in
criminal violence against women and we
and
there was one like new york times like
front page story i think
which just spun the story of this guy i
can't remember any of this because i
don't know which story it was um
but just buried buried buried what
should have been the lead
which was actually here the this this
person had been criminally violent just
the guy who
uh i don't remember okay well we'll stay
away from it yeah
particulars i think i know which story
you're talking about and yes the
um contrast between the actual story of
the individual
and the valorized version of the story
that was presented to the public was
like
we can heat like there are wrongful
deaths
by at the hands of police for sure
we can stand against that strongly and
fiercely
why would we valorize criminal behavior
well why would we do that so i want to
i want to spin it a little bit okay all
right let's spin
i want to twist to get it differently
turn it something um
here's the problem and you know eric has
done a thing where he's
called the uh the phenomenon optical
lynchings where
basically the point is if something
happens that can be portrayed as the
equivalent of a lynching then it is
grabbed onto irrespective of whether the
facts actually add up
right and so if it looks like a cop has
murdered somebody
then that's good enough because what
we're really looking for is something
symbolic we're not looking for a factual
case
the point though is in a world where
you've got
people let's say that they earnestly
believe
that police-based you know racially
motivated injustice
at the hands of police is a rampant
problem right right they are looking for
examples to point out what we all know
is taking place and the point is
how many of these examples have to turn
out to be
not at all the way they were portrayed
for us to conclude the obvious thing
which is that the
the case in which a truly innocent
person
a truly unarmed person is gunned down in
cold blood
right is actually rare right and so
i guess and of those cases the number of
those cases that have a racial component
is more rare right
so i think the point is the
question is actually pointing at the um
the elephant in the room which is it is
the rarity of cases that are truly
clean and in which there is no ambiguity
like this that causes the cases which
are so
compromised by the behavior of the
individual who's being valorized
to be so prominent yeah i mean
we probably don't want to spend a lot of
time here you know there is there's a
messiness here of course because i'm
reminded
in that argument of you know argument
that it's you know it's hard to bring a
rape con a rape case
against a guy uh if his victim wasn't
perfect
yeah right right if if she you know
especially if she was a sex worker but
if she um simply you know had a lot of
hookups if you know if she you know
like all of these things right and you
know the fact is that
rape should be rape with the
understanding that a whole lot of things
are being called rape that aren't
actually rape but like
rape is rape and it shouldn't matter
whether you know you
how the rest of the world views you and
whether or not
that should have happened to you well i
mean i agree with your point but i think
the thing is there's a difference
between somebody whose record is
imperfect in which case i do think
it is fair to ask the question you know
what disadvantages resulted in the
person's criminal behavior
on the other hand rape is a special
crime
right abuse against an individual right
sexual assault against women is a crime
against
an individual yeah and the point is that
if if the allegations are true then the
point is okay this person you're
valorizing
actually harmed somebody egregiously
and they had a choice it wasn't that
they stole to you know to feed a family
they actually engaged in sexual violence
against an individual human they don't
deserve to be valorized this is this is
a kind of crime for which there is no
excuse
it doesn't justify police violence but
um there's certainly no excuse for
valorization of the individual
right right exactly okay
happy birthday zach change of subject
also many thanks to zach for clarifying
my question about right to repair from
the 30th q a live stream
so zach you may know what he's talking
about there
all right um
change of pace here what are we at
time-wise sec
okay so we got a ton more great
questions so we're going to read a few
at least a few more of them before
switching
to the next to this hour's questions
people who have been
fully vaccinated can still spread the
virus question mark true
are there other examples of this outside
of kovid it seems like more scare
tactics
so this is something just got stated
today right was it fouchy
who i don't know someone just said this
well this
is apparently true um as far as i know
it's not um all that rare
because vaccines are essentially never
perfectly successful in preventing
disease
okay but but yeah yeah it seems to me
that you just conflated two things
if you are vaccinated and you
can't get it can you spread it
so then so so you you what you said
seems like it conflates these two things
and what fouchy or the who whoever's
saying this thing they're not being
clear
well the evidence is clear
right so well i i hope that's true like
every time i've tried to go
down this particular rabbit hole i can't
distinguish between these two
possibilities
because they're not they're not sharing
it so like if they are claiming that
somehow this
this magic virus and this magic vaccine
are combining in such a way
that if you're vaccinated you can't get
the thing but you can still spread it
like i don't know what planet we live on
and i really want to see what those data
look like but
that's not that's not what anybody's
saying okay you can get it
if you had the vaccine you can get it
and you're much more likely to be
asymptomatic because one thing that the
vaccine seems very good at is reducing
the severity of disease
which also reduces the degree to which
you are likely to transmit it
because right of course your symptoms
are a matter of the virus producing
on the other hand being vaccinated
you're less likely to be taking the same
kinds of precautionary measures
um to avoid spreading um and you are
going to think that you're immune to it
because you were vaccinated
and you know we did a whole takedown of
that crap paper on
asymptomatic spread being really really
common yeah but we still don't know
like we just took down that paper we
don't know to what degree of symptomatic
spread actually can happen
it's clearly less than symptomatic
spread but beyond that
we don't know and so if you've got
vaccinated people
who assume that they are now immune
whose a
small proportion of them are not but are
behaving as if they are
they will be if they do get it they will
be more likely to spread it than if they
had not been vaccinated
actually because they presumably would
have been behaving differently yes and
the frightening possibility here
is if you have been vaccinated
you have been vaccinated against the
original version of the spike protein
which means what are you likely to get
what is likely to get around
the immune system's uh vaccinated state
is a variant therefore if you spread it
what are you likely to spread
some variant from the vaccine pressure
for
a vaccine avoidant virus exactly again
welcome to the arms race right
cool um
clearly cultural institutions like the
aclu and most universities
no clearly cultural institutions
like the aclu and most universities were
up for sale and bought by billionaire
philanthropists making honest academics
scientists doctors journalists lawyers
etc hard to come by
just a comment but uh yeah i don't think
that's exactly how it happened i think
there's a much more organic
process well i think you know up for
sale is in quotes here anything up for
sale can mean a lot of different things
it can look a lot of different ways
there's a lot of ways there's a lot of
capture that can happen without there
being a placard on the door saying come
by us
right or without anybody consciously
attempting to do it of course
yeah um
someone is asked how they'll handle a
trade-off of two risks
they'll respond this one risk is bad no
mention of the other risk
can we come up with substitute can we
come up with a succinct term for this
non-answering tactic
i love this question i would love for us
and and it's possible it exists
so i'm just going to read it again so
it's clear what we're at i would love
to have a term for this and maybe you've
already got it
um so if you're asked how to handle two
risks and
or someone we'll call them alan is asked
how he'll handle a trade-off between two
risks and alan's like well i really
don't like that one
you're like alan you anything else like
you got anything for me no alan just
totally ignores the second risk
and this person fell asking the question
not alan
says can we come up with a succinct term
for this non-answering tactic
well i'm tempted to say one-side-ism
one-side-ism
you know because both side-ism is a um
an accusation that gets leveled at those
of us who
try to make arguments about how
something fits in context so
yeah there is whatever the answer to the
question is the question is an excellent
one this is a repeated problem
and you know it's a kind of if it's
willful it's sophistry
because what it does it's very hard
you know if you're trying to balance uh
the risk
of you know your building burning down
versus the risk of um
i don't know being unable to escape from
it or something
um the by focusing on one
argument it's very hard to make a
counter argument
right are you are you four buildings
burning down right
so um it distills something down to an
argument that is strong
but the point is the argument is
weakened only by the fact that there is
an argument in an inherent conflict with
it on the other side
yeah so a longer a sort of a dsm style
term would be sophistry colon one-sided
variant
[Music]
yeah i'm trying to think can we come up
with a really good example
trying to figure out what example we can
use as sort of the type specimen
uh i mean gosh i just feel like it
happens all the time you get people
saying well if you're if you know if
you're talking about
x that means you don't like like yeah
okay
i don't know i i can't come up with
anything right right now out of context
yeah it will occur to us but i feel like
it's all over the place yeah it is all
over the place so that i don't feel like
that's the hard part here at all
um the the hard part is the succinct
term so i'd love to come
back to this i don't know if we will
remember too because we always have
so many things but i'm going to at least
highlight this um
with my synesthesia 2 is blue
5 is red and 0 is white the first digit
is blue
so the number is mostly blue with faint
overtones of the other colors
is synesthesia adaptive and what might
its function be
oh you're gonna love this um
uh this is
uh i believe this is david eagleman's
work i certainly learned of it through
him
but it turns out that the synesthesia
thing where numbers have
colors to them is it's so
it's so gorgeous is apparently at least
largely the result of
toys that associate numbers with colors
like sets of blocks that have colors
on in different sides most foamy floor
mats yeah foamy floor mats for example
yeah that sounds like somebody's porn
name but
it's really bad porn i mean it all is
but
sure um no but if you've been a parent
in the last like
i don't know probably 30 years you uh
those
those floor mats with the numbers that
come out of them yeah um
but i don't i you know i
i have great respect for david and um i
don't know if this is his work
um i know you love this hype this
hypothesis it sounds like there's
evidence for it but um i don't
i don't know it feels it feels it feels
wrong it feels incomplete to me
it may be part in part and this is you
know this is where like
the lived experience of the personal
anecdote is like yeah but i don't think
that explains what happens for me
therefore
and so i mean i just i don't i'm not
saying it's wrong but i think it's
incomplete in part because
um those i i'm fascinated by synesthesia
and there's a great novel i'd have to
look it up about synesthesia that
um i i loved when i read it um that i'll
try to remember to look up here
um when i was actively thinking about it
a lot and i had exposure to a lot of
college students i would ask people and
a lot of people report mild levels and
you know it's not clear you know if
you're reporting mild levels like to
what degree you're just sort of clinging
to messages of childhood or whatever
um but there was never any pattern like
i was i actually took notes for a while
and i wouldn't know where to find them
now but i'm like what
what colors what peop what colors people
associate with what numbers
and um you know age cohorts geographic
cohorts like there was no pattern
to what numbers and colors associated
and so that made me
skeptical on the other hand you know
maybe there's so many different block
sets and
foam mats i don't know totally um i do
think the
i'm hesitating to say sure without
knowing the paper in question but i do
believe this this was a
properly tested hypothesis that
withstood test
i also think david uh had synesthesia
or maybe still does um so anyway an
insider
who for whom this resonated and who has
the relevant expertise i
i certainly take very seriously but um
it's certainly
an interesting explanation whether there
are multiple explanations it seems
likely that there yeah and i mean and
that's also a very narrow form so you
know it's anesthesia adaptive like
like i said i feel like it's um it's the
separating out of the senses that we
experience
as we age that's actually kind of like a
sensory apoptosis
actually kind of like that um so
apoptosis is programmed cell death
effectively like you know you start out
with effectively webbed fingers and then
the cells the this the tissue that you
don't need between your fingers
um over time um during development goes
away
um and you end up with you know and and
we have um this
you know overproduction of neurons in
the developing brain in the same way
and then um pruning down during early
development and
like through the ages well through
adulthood really but
um especially um early in childhood at a
couple of different
distinct moments in childhood and it's
not
that um it just you know there was just
too much it's like no actually more
connection is better like
more plasticity more capability is
better early on
and then you do get the term is
canalized you get you know you get you
basically go down particular canals and
i feel like
i feel like everyone has some kind of
synesthesia whether or not they've
recognized it or not early in childhood
and many of us retain at least a sort of
facultative ability to find it
even if we don't like i feel like i can
find a lot like
i can experience synesthetic things and
you know it's like it's like
anthogen's on call at some level um
but it's it never comes unbidden and
true synesthetes you know they live in
this world where for instance two is
two is blue and five is red and zero is
white um
but that you know the i feel like that's
just
less canalization like you know you
you're still more plastic and
having some people in a population that
have more plasticity in any realm and in
this case it's sort of
sensory failure to
failure to fully separate the senses
will have value um yeah i agree i also
like the idea
of what do you call it cognitive
apoptosis
sensory sensory apoptosis yeah i think
there's something
quite right about this that in childhood
you draw too many connections you see
things as related
too easily and that allows you to
discover
you know productive ways of thinking
that involve
pruning down so i think it is very much
that process um
there is a savant so in general
savants have extraordinary abilities
and extraordinary deficits coupled
there's one savant a mathematical savant
who is a synesthete there is a
documentary about him i'm trying to
remember his name
it's not late russian mathematician
vladimir i arnold is it oh no
because that's the next question no it's
not him okay um
too bad anyway it's a british guy okay
who appears to have no
i mean he's got some quirks but no major
deficit an extraordinary mathematical
capacity
and um anyway so it at least suggests
that synesthesia can be compatible with
extraordinary
capability but i would say in general
if everything we have discussed here is
true
then synesthesia in adults is not in and
of itself adaptive but it can be part of
adaptive ways of thinking
um if it was adaptive you would expect
it to be universal
so well no i mean if it's adaptive in
some circumstances or if it's adaptive
to have the variation
which was the argument i was making just
like left-handedness
is it's adaptive for some small fraction
of the population to be left-handed
okay so it could be a lineage level
adaptation right at the individual level
probably not but it is um
it is compatible with adaptive ways of
thinking right
okay have you guys heard of the late
russian mathematician vladimir i arnold
i sensed similar sentiments regarding
the nature of science and how to go
about learning it from some of his
writings may i recommend arnold's
swimming against the tide
i don't know i don't know him but uh
yeah um next one
another lizard that's not a lizard is
new zealand's tuatara
a beak head so i um just needed to
because um here zach just show my screen
here
um i of course have a slide from a
previous lecture on
wow that's terrible
um we are working without a net
she always abandons us yes again she she
didn't show for work
no um
oh that's good okay
no i didn't mean for so um tuataras
also known as uh beakheads also known as
wrinkocephalians yes um tuatara is the
maori for
i had it here somewhere oh i lost it oh
it's on it's on a different tuatara
slide of mine
um uh is maori for
uh spiny back i think is what zach can i
have my screen back
um and yeah oh it's the genus phenodon
spines on back um and they
are indeed not lizards but they are
sister to the squamates
uh so they are uh they are a string oh
did i show a picture okay
yeah is this the picture i just showed i
think it is this is a different one it's
a different picture
and i just screwed up this thing um oh
my god okay
um this is a different picture isn't it
yep oh so i was showing the wrong
picture entirely okay
um explains why i couldn't make it out
okay uh
this is the one i'm meant to be showing
god damn it nothing is working
um that is a tuatara there um
and they sure look lizardy right they
definitely have scales etc
um but here you know that we don't need
all the all the details but um
they are not lizards
and in part we can tell that because
unlike lizards they
don't have two penises they don't have
hemipenes
right yeah yeah in this case the fact
that they're not being lizards
it's really close it's a bit arbitrary
because
the uh basil lizard was lizard-like
um and so we could just include that we
could arbitrarily
have decided to call the larger group
that includes tuatara's
um hazards yeah yeah i'm looking for a
tree now i've got all sorts of trees
with all sorts of
extinct reptiles and that won't do it
yeah
all right yeah cool didn't think two
guitars were going to come up today but
like
stop talking about squamates um
which type of questions arise more
naturally in you is it a
what something is or how did something
come to be whatever you think it is
thank you for the podcast by the way i
look forward to your next episode every
sunday
um yeah very much how and why
so um so what
is really just a is a definitional like
identity thing
and um easily determined and
not that interesting how questions are
are interesting and a lot of the
research that's that's done now is based
on how questions sort of levels of
questions of mechanism um how does the
heart function
how does the bird migrate um
you know how does um skin regrow
after it comes off um but why
questions are really the evolutionary
questions the so-called ultimate levels
of analysis
um so um you know why do birds and
mammals both have four chambered hearts
um and you know why do
birds with long childhoods have more
efficient migrations
than birds with no relationship with
their parents it's true
why um i don't know what's the other
thing skin
i don't have one for skin um
yeah i would say i'm also uh thoroughly
animated by
why but i do also have a fascination
with the border between the how and the
why
um there is something to be said for
thinking in mechanistic terms in order
to deduce
the answers to the why questions you
know
to give an example early on in covid
you and i were both struck by the
fascinating fact of
viral load in a room predicting
the likelihood of catching covid and the
idea that even
in a room in which there was cove but if
you were there briefly or the windows
were open
that somehow you wouldn't cross some
threshold which does not fit
with the model of immunity
that we call acquired
but it does fit pretty well with innate
immunity
where you have a certain number of cells
capable of doing generalist
immunological work that become
overwhelmed
by the number of particles they
encounter so as long as you remain below
some threshold
uh your innate immunity works really
well so in any case the point is
the question the fact that things didn't
fit with the
model of immunity that we typically
think about
raises a question about what else might
be going on at the mechanistic level
underneath
that is worth thinking about and it
turns out that there's a very
rich answer to the question so anyway i
love those things
yeah and i will say i think
evolutionary biology has been uh slow
to wake up to mechanism for totally
arbitrary historical reasons which were
when evolutionary um theory began to be
vibrant starting with darwin we didn't
have the tools to look into
mechanism below a certain scale and so
we got used to evolutionary bio just got
used to thinking
purely phenomenologically and not at all
mechanistically and then when mechanism
the study of mechanism caught up because
suddenly we had all of these great tools
there was sort of a loss of interest you
know or the interest didn't arise
because it didn't sound
interesting in evolutionary terms but
that the interface
really often is very interesting and i
wish both sides cared about it more
very good one more question here and
we'll pick up some of these next time
before moving to
this hour's super chat why has any
discussion of the vaccine nanoparticles
disappeared
did anyone discover how the particles
break down in the body could they be
causing the clots
i think i did not look into this but i
think that the clots are mostly
happening with the dna vaccines
the astrazeneca and the jnj vaccines
although
you know six and six million is not it
was it was it clots was it six and six
million
six point seven million or whatever um
was it klotz anyway you know that's a
whole other story um but um anyway the
dna vaccines don't have the
nanoparticles the lipid nanoparticles
which is
part of why we were more excited about
those um they still have the novel
mechanism
a novel mechanism but they don't have
two novel mechanisms
as the rna mrna vaccines do so uh
i don't know if clots have been
associated with either
moderna or pfizer stuff has been
associated with them
i don't trust that we're seeing actually
what the data are and
and what kinds of symptoms you know it's
just an anecdotal level i've
heard from a ton of people who report
like really severe rashes that don't go
away for instance
um and you know i don't see that in the
press
so um
why is any discussion the vaccine
nanoparticles particles disappeared
um we're not allowed to criticize these
i think is the basic terrible answer
well i also i don't think we figured out
what they do
no i don't think we figured out what
they what the particle breakdown in the
body
my guess is there's not enough particles
for the breakdown in the body
um to have much consequence it's not
impossible
yeah it's not going to be breakdown so
much but here's the
the thing that i that i never here
discussed
the mechanism by which the rna
vaccines enter the cell is
new so too will be
the distribution of cells
that are entered and the reaction of the
immune system
to them in other words i think that a
lot of the novel
symptoms that we are seeing are likely
to be due
to the haphazard way in which
a bunch of rna dumped into the body
inside
these nanoparticle envelopes ends up
entering
cells and causing some tissue therefore
to malfunction
to some degree right so the point is
you're dumping these things into the
system very imprecisely right you're
injecting them
into muscularly and that means that they
will disperse
in some way and some fraction of the
cells they encounter
they will enter and those cells will
start making spike protein and
exporting it to their surface and the
point is well
what symptoms would you expect and the
answer is that expect a bit of chaos
yeah that's not a very precise system
right you're not introducing it into a
particular place where the cells
then pick it up and do something very
coordinated you're dumping enough into
the system
that enough cells pick it up that it
results in enough of the immune system
encountering it that you get
a robust immune reaction that creates
memory
um but this is like you know
this is a bunker buster bomb
right it's not a precision response
and uh how we discuss yeah the lipid
nanoparticles are the armor
right so that they what is it the rna
aces i'm not pronouncing that right um
basically that are circulating
constantly don't get to the rna before
it can get inside a cell
um and so the armor is then just left in
pieces
floating around the body and hopefully
hopefully collected and discarded but
yeah well yeah i mean it you know i
think actually it's going to get
integrated into cell
membranes right and
you know like like like plastic micro
particles and fishes
well you know at some level the surfaces
of these cells are lipid
which is why the lipid envelope works
right it's sort of like two bubbles
fusing together
um but you're doing this
almost at random with respect to tissue
and and are those
are the lipid nanoparticles more or less
coherent under certain types of stress
right like
at the point that you get heat shock for
instance
you know are they more are they going to
be more resistant and therefore the
cells won't lice when they should
you know or you know less like there's
just all sorts of possibilities
yep and and we don't know yeah we don't
know that's the answer that's
unfortunately that's the answer
okay next question a school in australia
made the boys apologize to the nearest
girl for the behavior of men
justified by the idea of ubiquitous male
culture making all men responsible for
the actions of a few
does such a culture exist
um i don't understand that last part
yeah i don't understand that justified
by the idea
of a ubiquity i think i think what is
being asked is
this was justified by this idea of
ubiquity a male culture that is
ubiquitous
um in which in which men are
you know all men are toxic basically and
no no it doesn't
um yeah they're yeah there will there
will be
some moments in history in some cultures
uh under times of extreme stress
and war when all men are called upon uh
to become
toxic right like that will happen but um
i that's about as that's about as close
as i can get
i mean it just doesn't make any sense
yeah men and women are part of the same
culture and there can be subcultures in
there that travel
one route or the other but yeah um not
all men
are toxic obviously that has become a
cliche but it is
important to say it in this context and
frankly those kids are
due an apology yes they are yeah
all of them the boys and the girls yep
and an explanation not just an apology
uh i don't because obviously apologies
have become weapons
and they aren't actual apologies and we
need to also resurrect apology as
a powerful and necessary force for human
interactions
because this thing where you just
apologize when the mob comes from you i
hope that it goes on to the next victim
is not really an apology and it's moving
the
it's it's moving the mob to the next
victim is all it's doing
it's externalizing the mob and it's and
so most people now know that an apology
isn't an apology and we need it
we need it um and you know when if
if the thing comes for you and tells you
that all you need to do is apologize and
it'll go away
and um it'll make nice with you don't
believe it and don't apologize
don't do it uh it's part of
it's part of what we did at evergreen
right and in fact
i think well we refused to um
to do any sort of non-disclosure
agreement
um and the very first thing they asked
for us when we got into
um mediation
was an apology from us
and we're like i think we're done like
what are you doing
yep crazy yeah um
i don't see a way out of this that does
not include giving law enforcement
permission to kill rioters
please tell me why i'm wrong florida
made it okay to run over protesters
blocking roads
what are your thoughts um
we can't do this yeah but uh the fact is
there are
tactical things you could do it is
impossible to do these
to do what is necessary in the case of
an anarchist force that is trying to
precipitate violence against them
in order to justify more of this so we
can't
well i'm reminded of um a conversation
you had early in the protests and riots
um with someone who was who was
i can't remember police or or or
military uh who'd been called in uh who
was saying they're taking all of our
non-lethal
methods of enforcement away from us yeah
he was federal
federal police that's right and um you
know
first before you even start to think
about going there
um give the police back all of their
non-lethal tools
yeah not non-lethal they're less lethal
and that does mean
you know well tear gas isn't lethal
uh yes also especially lethal
let's just say i don't like the idea
that we are held to non-lethal you've
got people who are destroying
civilization
and the fact is it makes sense to use
tools
that allow the law to be enforced and do
not do more harm than necessary
but you can't let the fact that they're
going to do some harm
stop you and the fact is i would be
shocked
if tear gas had never killed anybody
you know just the simple fact that it's
stressful on the body is
dangerous to something that's fine the
fact is um
if they had they were calling for
defunding the police and they
effectively did
and they got they managed to at least in
portland get rid of most of the
lesser kinds of control
tools that the police normally would be
using and no one said you also need to
disarm the police because frankly
even the even the [ __ ] who were
leading this thing knew what would
happen then
if it was understood that the police had
literally no arms
and so what they're left with is their
arms what they're left with is their
most lethal tools
and yes they need those but wouldn't it
be much better if they also had their
entire panoply
um so you know fine yes all of these
tools can be lethal under the wrong
circumstances but
um we don't start now having taken
all of these tools off the table by
saying okay well you can kill them no
you give them back all the tools and you
actually start
um you know arresting and booking and
sentencing
some of these fools yes like that's what
you have to do
you have to yeah i i totally agree with
that
um yeah and i mean i frankly if it were
me
i would give a speech and i would say
the law has to be enforced
here's why it'd be lovely if we could do
it without
damaging anyone we'll do our best but
don't expect nobody to be damaged
because
this is the nature of the thing that
we're up against um here are the tools
that we intend to use they're not
perfectly safe
you know the wise thing to do would be
to obey the law and
not destroy property or attack people
and that speech having been made um stop
being so damn nice to the people who are
destroying life for everyone else
okay um thank you for last hour's video
of the coyote den it's a nice diversion
in these times
you're welcome glad somebody liked it i
thought
it's uh it's hard to get footage like
that we got very
lucky to find the den and we were lucky
to be able to get a camera on it quick
enough because
she wasn't going to stick around yeah
and we did get a picture
right or a slight bit of video of the
first kit being pulled out
as well yes we we got it in which she's
in which the kit is more visible so it's
clear that there's two of them because
it's
two different time stamps in all of this
right
because i had i had looked in and i had
said oh there's two i thought there
might be more movement but there's two
and then um when you would look you're
like i'm not sure
i'm not sure there's two i was like gosh
i really feel certain
it may so and then and we know because
we have
we have cam video evidence that there
were two there were only two
there were definitely two yeah yep
unless she was carrying more than one in
her mouth at the time which i don't
think she would have done mm-hmm
and inju the first one which we showed
you the kid is screaming screaming
screaming and the
in the one that we didn't show you which
actually came first um
he's quiet yeah totally silent hopefully
alive
presumably like she wouldn't have
started there oh yeah he is making
noises just not
yeah thanks mom um
punk band bad religion did an album the
gray race
founder g gaffin is an evolutionary
biologist
how long would it take for populations
to breed to a new race
would it increase genotype variation
um so i don't know anything about the
setup i don't know anything about the
album or anything
yeah i don't either i would say the
thing about humans
is that we have a special trick that
allows us to behave
like many species though we are one and
so it it already you know the
distinction between
uh bedouins and inuits
is a huge gap in terms of how these two
populations
function it's a species and beyond level
gap but within one species so
anyway humans are nifty and therefore
it's
the question is does the thing you're
asking even makes sense given how much
human beings do
within one genetic umbrella
it's uh it's a whole different realm and
it would be
worth trying to ask the question with
the with the right
sort of schema but it's you know this
isn't well understood in the field so
yeah we don't have that set of terms and
and
and uh even if we were talking about
rabbits say
um and therefore we just taught using
the word population
rather than race like subspecies which
you know races are not but
in over in non-human um space
we would be talking about different
subspecies um
and time isn't a sufficient
variable like you need to know the
degree of isolation size of the
population
amount of immigration immigration and
mutation
and selection on various characters that
might further isolate like you know you
just you need a lot more
that you can't it can't just be about
time and then
you know in humans you know subspecies
is a is a dicey
as a dicey term race is a dicier term
and it's a
um it's a largely
inaccurate rendering of what populations
are
and with humans becoming global as long
ago as we did
it's a really poor map for actual
population level differences at the
genetic level
yeah i would say the
amount of time given a set of
circumstances necessary
for two populations not to be able to
understand each other
would be a good proxy
humans to not to understand so language
right
yeah that's good
um i know this word and i never know how
to pronounce it
can you take a look um are you familiar
with us versus crookshank
okay the scotus decision uh that
acquitted white racists who committed
the colfax massacre and opened the door
to jim crow
it's part of a history of racist gun
control laws that stood until 2008.
i know of it but not enough to say
anything i've heard of it but i don't
have it
um but sounds important and uh
of course it has to exist because to
have um
liberal gun laws and constitutional
protections
with as much racial tension as we have
you have to have some sort of mechanism
for differential enforcement
in order for uh the racist past to be
what it is
um so anyway yes there would have to be
a history of this and i wish
i'm surprised we don't know it but we
should look into it yeah
uh could an ancestor to the current
sarsko v2 virus be similar enough to
generate an immune response to the
current virus
and different enough to be much less
lethal oh absolutely 100
absolutely absolutely theoretically
possible will we ever know wow a lot of
questions here okay let's get to
say three more sure um
oh happy birthday zach by the way
heather there are over a hundred
thousand black bears in alaska alone
okay but i don't include alaska north
america just canada 100 000 black bears
in alaska that's amazing that's
incredible i had obviously no idea
i'm ready to go you do love your bears i
do love bears yeah
that's really cool thank you i sit
corrected
uh um
to the earlier comment about activists
screenshotting super chats and using
them against the talent
even if the majority of virtuous one
person spending twenty dollars to make
someone look bad is a cheap investment
in d
platforming right okay
i now understand the super chat part of
it and yeah we've had a couple
weird questions but um by and large our
community of people in the chat
is as far as i know by far the best
anywhere on youtube youtube is such a
horror show and by and large we have
very good people in the chat
and yeah um we have very good moderators
and uh anyway i'm i'm proud of what we
got messy as it is
okay uh two more questions what is your
current thinking on relative vaccine
safety
heather i believe you said that you
would prefer a viral vector vaccine for
yourself
thoughts on the recent blood clot
stories um
there's a lot of questions in there um
we already talked a little bit about the
blood clot
stuff you know that i think it's again
it's like
i hope that the blood clot stories are
like the seat belts in the car the
vaccine is still
affording greater safety than um then
uh then damage i think pulling j and j
or proposing that people should be
cautious about j and j for six
bad cases in over six million is an
insane thing to have done
that's that those numbers make no sense
um i still wish that we had many more
years behind us of these vaccines before
we were being expected to take them
um we will be eligible to get vaccinated
soon here
in oregon um and uh i would
i hope j j remains available and um
that we can wait as long as possible
yeah i would say
the number of ways in which this is
unsafe are many and it is clear and we
are not
having a proper public discussion about
it kev and i are having a proper
discussion
but i don't hear it elsewhere there's
the personal safety dimension
there's the safety of this vaccination
campaign
there is the danger of the way markets
are interfacing
with the various vaccines on offer
you know is there a perverse incentive
driving the claim that we may need
a third uh booster um
is there a perverse incentive that
results in proclamations about the
danger of one vaccine versus another
is there a perverse incentive preventing
us from discussing
both the long-term risks of these
vaccines and the risk of affecting the
pandemic
in a way that will make things worse and
not better all of these things are
absent from the discussion
and they exist only discussed on the
fringe and that's
absurd and in light of all of this the
idea that we are going to be
forced with vaccine passports to accept
vaccinations
that have not been about which no one
has been honest about the hazards
is extremely distressing it's diabolical
it's diabolical and i would say you know
what
in a good regime in a regime in which we
did proper due diligence about vaccine
safety
in which there were no perverse
incentives surrounding
the mythology about which ones are safe
and how safe they are and all of that
i would be in favor of vaccine passports
but
i am not at all in favor of them in the
context
of a system that will not discuss
rationally what the actual hazards might
be
i don't think they're safe enough
last question new york father pulls his
daughter out of brearly
with a message to the whole school is
the damn starting to break
yeah i have not read the letter i'm
aware of it um
certainly in the last month or two um
from from what i've seen largely through
the efforts of barry weiss
and um caitlyn flanagan
um we this
the problems with the wokeness in the
elite private schools in particular
elite private um secondary schools is
coming to a head
is becoming really uh well
known in some circles that said
the rhetoric that we see
in other places looks unchanged
um as if as if that's not happening at
all
so i don't know i don't know what it
takes i know that
um gosh i think it was
fall of 2019 that james lindsay
said that he thought it was happening
damn was breaking people were becoming
aware of it
it's like i don't think so man like i
think
i i just i don't think it's where you
think it is and of course it didn't
yeah yeah well it only continued to get
worse um so
you know there's been a lot of these
moments um and
i i guess i don't want to get my hopes
up
well here's a frightening prospect um i
agree with you there the chances that
we've hit bottom
it always seems like we might have and
then things just get stupider but
um imagine that the elite schools
wake up and the parents who get it
you know and there are likely to be many
successfully fight back and then
once again we have another version of
this trick
that involves the distinction between
private schools and public schools
right where we underfund the public
schools
those who can afford to send their kids
to private schools don't suffer from
having hobbled their kids in bad public
schools
and it creates a self-reinforcing
pattern
of the distribution of opportunity that
nobody needs to
uh own up to having created in other
words sabotage the public schools
um privately subsidize the private
schools so that they're better
and the point is what is that that's the
wealthy hobbling other people's children
so they can't compete
yeah i mean it's it's kind of the
opposite at the moment like the private
schools are worse
but imagine that they come to their
senses and suddenly the only schools
that aren't insane
are elite private schools right one can
easily imagine that world because we've
lived in it
i guess um i i i mean i guess i'm not
sure why we're imagining
the world that is the inverse of the one
we're in right now which is plenty bad
enough
and um because wealthy people
have the means to erect their own system
if they need to
and that in effect
seeing a novel version of an old game
would not be surprising
something that will need to happen um so
it was
it was a father right that pulled his
daughter out
um that wrote this letter and pulled it
out and i think um
the damn is going to have to break with
the mothers
if that's going to happen and you know
you're imagining that this amazing thing
happens
and then it becomes yet another
reinforcement of class privilege
rather than talk about the damn having
the amazing thing having happened and
then
one of the possible immediate after
effects
i think for that damned break um the
the tougher parent in most situations
to see this ideology for what it is and
to resist it and to be disagreeable
and to stand up to it and to say i don't
think so not for me of course i care
about black people
this is really uncomfortable why did i
just lose all my friends
it's gonna it's gonna be mothers and um
i think you know so far many of the
examples
um we're seeing like barry weiss posted
a piece written by a teacher at an elite
school on the east coast
this week who's standing up to this a
male teacher you know and
these are anecdotes but um i think what
we what we need for the dam to break is
for more for more
women to stand up and say actually i'm
going to change
the um the expectation in the community
that we don't do this
that this is actually this thing that we
are all on board with is actually the
diabolical thing
um because that's it's it's much
it's just going to be necessary if
things are going to change yeah
so actually it's i think you're making a
very important point
um i mean this is just apropos
as you know and i think i mentioned
maybe last week and i've been i've been
asked to write this
commentary on a piece on um
historical relationships between women
and men and women and men and all this
but like
deep historical relationships between
women and how it affects
relationships today and i've been
thinking about the different kinds of
competition that men engage in
yeah and that women engage in and what
that looks like when men and women
interact and
and how much we pretend that those that
deep history doesn't exist
back when and um and and to to
in our to our peril right and so so much
of the literature
is just insanely stupidly written the
scientific literature of course because
it always is it says things like well
women
don't compete women say they don't like
to compete therefore they don't compete
women when asked to engage in this you
know
doodly competitive thing said they
didn't want to play therefore women
don't compete it's like
oh my god like of course women compete
women compete all the time just as much
as men
but um but differently and and you know
in a word
it tends to be that men tend to compete
overtly and women tend to compete
covertly and there are so many
downstream effects of this
that are that are so important that it
will also be and this is something i
think this is
new i think no one has said this before
will also be harder to opt out
of covert than overt games yeah then
covert than over
competition because as a man you can
like say
yep not playing and you might get chided
for it you might get shamed for it but
everyone knows he's not playing he's
doing
something different right and if the
competition is covert
it's all behind the back and it's gossip
and it's sidelining and it's social and
you know like you can't just say like
i'm not playing yeah
you're like oh yes you are we're not
going to let you not play so
she's not playing oh that's a really
good move
and sometimes it will be yeah right
sometimes sometimes that is a that is
a move actually so anyway like i'm
wrapped up in this
in this space anyway but i in order for
this damn to break we need
women who are somewhat dominant in
whatever little social hierarchies
they're in
at these schools to actually make the
moves to make it you know to make it the
desirable position
to be standing up to this because until
that happens
those few dads who stand up and do it
are you know
are are not going to make the difference
i don't think so i think i just want to
put three things on the list here you've
mentioned disagreeableness which is more
common
exactly i did so intentionally right
this is a necessary skill to say no
in the face of something like this right
there is the question of compassion
this movement hijacks compassion and
compassion compassion is going to be
more easily hijacked in women very
likely it's probably a more
uh more intensely developed skill the
nature of being female being one that
requires this
you know more directly for mothering for
example
right um and then there's the question
about this distinction between males and
females in terms
of the preferences for the types of
things they engage in and
so the classic way to describe it is
people versus things where men tend to
be more interested in things women tend
to be more interested in people
and the thing is people is a
yeah the thing is i said it i said it
because i'm masculine
no the thing is that the world of things
is a world of conservation laws that is
unforgiving
right and so the world of conservation
laws is one
in which one discovers that certain
that an illogical system does not
function right
a world of people does not necessarily
have conservation laws in the same sense
and so there's a question about
um whether there is a a gender split
here that might be
setting us up for disaster yeah don't
don't feel like you have to cut it short
i just have you know about eight things
to say in response you know so there's
we have talked about you know being
spending understanding something about
the physical world as opposed to being
entirely based in the social world and
that you know that does map somewhat
onto things versus
people and so given that it is a you
know well-replicated psychological
finding
that men are and you know including
babies including other cultures right
like
more interested in things on average
tendency and women in people
and animals right um that that would
also suggest
that many women have
more of their entire life invested in
the relationships that they have and so
it actually comes at a cost to more
a higher percentage of their life to go
against the crowd whereas men if they're
engaged with these things that actually
are meaningful to them they can go to
their damn shop
be like okay well i stood up to that and
now i get to tinker you know whatever it
is
you know it's a caricature but it's not
your whole world it's not your entire
world collapsing
um so they're just you know i haven't
actually
found even the typical character trait
by
by gender that goes against this model
like it all just like falls
which which makes it you know this is
one of the few things i'm like god
did someone really smart devise this to
you know capture women and then take out
a whole society because this seems so
deviously perfect to to prey on many of
the best characteristics of women and
turn them into the worst characteristics
for society yeah um i mean it's hard to
even say these things out loud but at
some level this does you know the whole
um the whole woke ideology
feels like it has dragged civilization
into the dynamics
of a uh a dysfunctional merit
right it feels i mean it just does and
um yeah i mean i i don't like
saying it on the other hand it's not
like everything isn't at stake we're
actually
talking about you know the dumbest
policy proposals one could conceive of
and yet we are entertaining them because
nobody's in a position to say
actually you can't abolish the police
here's why end of story right that's
what you need to say
right sorry boston police not on the
table here's why
um so anyway yeah um
we need we need we need more
disagreeable women
on it all right
you can only be one disagreeable woman
i'm i don't know
i'm i don't know what to say yeah
um all right uh that is it this is a
chaotic weird day today both of us
really want to be outside so we're going
to encourage
you to get outside as soon as possible
even if it's the middle of the night why
not
do it in the meantime subscribe
like this this video this channel
the clips channel to consider joining me
and my patreon
heather heing where right now you can
pose questions that we may get to in our
next
private q a consider joining brett his
patreon
[Music]
lots more to be said but anything else
uh achieve awesomeness
do that all right see ya
[Music]
you